once you say marry your mothers and
alcohol
you can't dance magic it's got no hook
go to your room you found it because you
like terrible music that was before
cosas no me dance Dennis I got a song so
I talk from side salsa wait to practice
no jam with people your own age oh nice
one
Oh Dexter I don't like it it's boring I
know might be still mad at me for
bringing us here one day lighting the
hip-hop world on fire collecting all
your source Awards and thank me source
Awards is that as far as I get in your
dream alright alright you guys get a
grammy or something yeah yeah let me get
some claps y'all yeah yeah hey mr.
Morris I'm Kathleen you make you my play
Oshkosh Allah hello why you out here
causing trouble
I didn't do anything start thinking with
your brain and not your dick hey nobody
speak nobody get choked only facts I
will shoot up
big quack with a Ruger can you up get up
come on a sick [ __ ] I'm my best
screaming guess what more cannot sleep
love make you do some stupid things
nobody sweet nobody okay I'll go as a
girls always a girl Bo there's no rush
say here you want it by the cops he's a
gangster gangster rapper I'm not trying
to keep you from experiencing anything
so I'm not in trouble
oh no you grounded like a mother kid to
shoot another day if the owners willing
to sell we're trying to persuade you ask
politely people listen are there more
beautiful girls in Hollywood or New York
why is that how you'll decide where
you'll live you're very beautiful